listen listen listen listen that's how I
start all my rest because I don't know
it what the [ __ ] I'm saying talk to you
like you deaf listen I'm listening [ __ ]
what the [ __ ] hey what is going on
YouTube do videos in two days have I
lost my mind yes today all of you came
in unison and sent me a very disturbing
video because you found out I was back
on my youtube grind for the next few
weeks yeah cute little dingleberry [ __ ]
for those of you out there who have not
seen this video you guys are going to
see a man who is going to be forcibly
removed from his seat on a plane that he
already paid and booked for by United
Airlines now this doesn't sound so bad
but when I say forcibly I'm using that
word very lightly so once again if you
haven't seen this video hold your damn
dick skin cuz this one gets a little
rough
give me just give me thank you me me now
I'm just gonna go ahead and get right
into this what the [ __ ] is going on have
lost your [ __ ] mind now as you guys
may already know I already hate airlines
and I already hate airplanes but United
you want the [ __ ] list a long
time figure out what's going on here a
man who already booked paid at boarded
the plane is forcibly being removed
unnecessarily because you United
overbooked the flight and I'll be it
let's say in the worst case scenario he
was causing a scene he was very upset
the solution to that is to bodyslam it
into a [ __ ] armrest what I'm gonna
say this though [ __ ] I wish a
[ __ ] would not because I'm
saying I would kick their [ __ ] ass
because I got soft hands but if you
gonna force me out my seat like that
[ __ ] you go work for it I would love to
see you drag my fat ass off a plane when
I go full on dead weight and I did if
you go full dead weight for some reason
you just automatically gain like a
hundred pounds and on squishy [ __ ]
maybe like trying to drag a giant
octopus through a pile of seagard [ __ ]
mm-hmm that's what you would look like
trying to track me off now let's talk
about the story behind this according to
multiple passengers on that flight and
from United Airlines themselves now
before ship got out of hand United did
the airline type of thing to do which is
to offer somebody a counter offer for
their seat they initially offered a $400
voucher and a one-night Hotel State and
a flight tomorrow morning nobody wanted
to get off the plane that didn't work so
they offered 800 instead and still
nobody took the bait
so as a solution a United official on
the intercom decided to say do you mean
we have United appoint that need to fly
out tonight and we are not leaving here
until four people get off this plane
goddamn it but because their kind words
didn't work they decided to choose four
passengers at random two people that
were picked at random was a doctor and
his wife
and this doctor told him that he could
not leave his plane because he had
patients to see tomorrow and so he
needed to stay on this flight to get
home after being upset and having a bit
of a back-and-forth they decided to go
ahead and call the police at Chicago
O'Hare Airport take him body slamming
onto his face
- an armrest causing him to bleed that
may drag his lifeless body on out the
plane makes [ __ ] sense right now when
I hear stories like this I always like
to reserve my opinions because there's
always two sides to the story
so you just really want to pump your
brakes before you go ahead and do these
type of you know commentaries or video
but United this one's a little bit tough
to pick you up um especially when you
come out with a [ __ ] PR apology like
this this is an obsessive end to all of
us here at United I apologize for having
to be accommodating these customers our
team is moving with a sense of urgency
to work with the authorities and conduct
our own detail reveal what happened we
are also reaching out to this passenger
to talk directly to them and further
address every solve this situation
I hate these type of [ __ ] PR [ __ ]
apologies that is not an apology or even
close to an explanation of what happened
and what you're going to do to resolve
this situation a sense of urgency we
accommodate subtle cameltoe [ __ ]
the only way United for you to better
this solution is for you to apologize to
the Asian dr. Asian style lay some
broken glass on the floor get on your
knees and a hold three calculus books
above your head or option B you need to
take some sriracha open up the goddamn I
bow stick some razors and squeeze that
[ __ ] right in there - and to add insult
to injury the Chicago Police Department
which operates separately from the
Chicago O'Hare security and police
decide to put this out at a statement
which was terrible that the man fell
into the armrest oh wow what a domestic
violence cases went that way sir did you
strike your wife
oh no I blocked her face with my face
okay what and just to stop a few you out
there that are on the airport side
saying [ __ ] like well that was only
within their rights to do so if he does
not comply it's his fault
oh because it's kind of funny because
the Aviation Department decided to
release a statement to the Chicago
sun-times
Hey United flight three four one one was
not in accordance with our standard
operation procedure [ __ ] and the
actions of the aviation security officer
are obviously not condoned [ __ ] by the
department well you just got first
comment great face well he could have
gotten off the plane like a normal
person and got on a different flight
it's clearly possible well [ __ ] that
means that that airline had other
options that employees who by the way
were overbooked could have got on two
instead of forcing it past two who
already paid for his ticket to leave you
don't make any [ __ ] sense you dumb
[ __ ] you know interesting ly enough at
the reading like four or five maybe six
articles about this a lot of people are
kind of bringing the whole race thing
into this I don't know if the race thing
is you know really involved I'm not
upset because he's an Asian man that
this happened to whether it was the
Asian person of white person black or
Mexican I would still be upset because
this is an issue of treating a human
being like this there's no reason to
bring up the fact that he's Chinese or
Asian just watching that video and as a
human being was hard enough as it is
let me ask you guys what do you think a
better solution for this problem was do
you think United should be held
responsible for this should they do a
better apology leave it in the comments
below and a lot of you guys have been
asking like you know what would I have
done in that situation well to be honest
with you you know the moment they said
hey here's 800 bucks in a hotel to look
you straight in the eye say hey listen
to me deal [ __ ] cheap and I broke I
don't know you know anything else I
probably would have tried out you know
hustle them a little harder what about
1200 tomorrow then you got a deal a big
boy oh yeah hey what is going on YouTube
yes I hope you guys liked that video all
I was so upsetting just to watch but you
guys know we got to do it we gotta you
know we got to get our rant on we got to
get a conversation on I love you
[ __ ] stay tuned for more videos
once again I don't know when things are
gonna go up but Sundays at 12 p.m. I
will always be there but I might upload
a few more here and there I'm thinking I
might do another month on this Sunday uh
uh might be my favorite fried rice
recipe kimchi fried rice [ __ ] suck my
nuts love you guys from his plane on a
United Airlines Eric what the [ __ ]
my same